the king of spring break a wedding
planner ready for anything and a
character so evil just hearing his name
sends people into a rage Roger Smith had
many classic personas over the years on
American Dad here are his best
Roger has created several personas who
have pursued criminal careers outside of
the Smith household and one of them is
the professional fake ID seller Kevin
ramage heavily tattooed and dotted with
piercings ramage appears as a low-level
Street Thug trying to intimidate Haley
and Steve who are pushing into his Turf
in the counterfeit license business in
season 9's faking bad as part of his
intimidation tactics ramage orders his
Burly twin henchmen to beat him up in
front of Haley and Steve promising the
Smith kids that such rough treatment is
waiting for them if they don't leave his
territory after Steve has falling out
with Haley later in the episode he joins
with ramage's outfit quickly getting in
over his head when ramage arranges a
deal to sell fake IDs to a drug cartel a
Slim Shady look-alike ramage is a
hopelessly inept crook whose
incompetence knows no bounds despite
thinking he's a legitimate criminal
ramage is anything but with the latter
part of the episode showing just how
humorously out of his element He is when
it comes to hardcore criminals like the
Armenian mob
and Rama
one of the most kind-hearted and
genuinely decent of Roger's many
personas Tom yabo is a down-to-earth
yoga Enthusiast who Mary Stan's mother
in season 8's American stepdad though
Stan initially thinks Roger has only
married his mother Betty as a way to
keep a spot in the house since Stan was
going to kick Roger out of the attic so
that his mother could move in however he
soon grows closer to Tom forming a close
paternal bond with him as they spend
more and more time together however the
entire marriage is soon revealed to be
part of a scheme planned by Betty to
cash in on Tom's life insurance policy
despite Betty's scheme Tom still uses
the opportunity to form a father-son
relationship with Stan during the
episode we see Stan go from distrusting
Roger to watching them partake in
cliched family activities given Roger's
pettiness and selfishness in the past we
assume the worst about Roger's
motivations at first the most unexpected
thing about the episode is that Tom has
been genuine the entire time using his
marriage to Betty as a way to actually
bond with Stan Roger doesn't have many
likable or sympathetic personas under
his belt which makes Tom a special kind
of character by the end of the episode
we can't help but be surprised by Tom's
cathartic interactions with Stan finally
giving the Surly CIA agent the Father
Figure he always wanted
a riff on 2000 era team comedies Scotch
Bingington appears in season three's
spring breakup in the episode Roger
creates Scotch as the ultimate party
animal having grown angry over an MTV
program detailing the previous year's
wildest spring break party seeking to
throw the ultimate College bash and be
crowned king of spring break Roger takes
the opportunity to throw a massive party
while Francine is away inviting busloads
of college students to the Smith
residence by the time Francine has left
for her parents place Roger has almost
completely converted the Smith household
into the ideal party Mansion within the
span of the few minutes Roger installs a
margarita-filled waterfall a lazy ride
filled with beer a human-sized hamster
wheel and a huge stage in the backyard
sporting a homemade crown and with a
scepter that shoots Chivas Regal Scotch
is very much the stereotypical College
frat row as American Dad fans are sure
to know when Roger gets a specific goal
in his said he goes the extra mile to
make it happen Scotch brings out all of
Roger's craziest Carefree treats and
amplifies them tenfold
as handsome as Clark Gable and his Suave
as James Bond Dan and some handsome is
described by Francine as Roger's most
Charming Persona a character that women
can't resist Dan and some handsome no
woman can resist him whoa just hearing
his name makes me hot Dan appears in the
season 7 episode The Scarlet getter
Roger is spitting when he meets CIA
agent Scarlett Reynolds an old Crush of
stents Stan scoffs at the notion that
Roger could romantically pursue someone
like Scarlet offending Roger when
Francine grows irritated by Stan mooning
over his old Crush she invites Roger to
interact with Scarlett as the Debonair
Dan and some handsome and it appears to
work despite Scarlett's attraction to
Dan being a ruse that put her one step
closer to capturing Roger on behalf of
the CIA something can certainly be said
about the on-screen presence Dan and
some handsome commands making his
introduction by sliding down the
banister of the Smith staircase while
mixing a martini Dan and some handsome's
reputation precedes him he's definitely
one of the most charismatic personas
we've seen Roger portray to date
Far and Away Roger's wealthiest Persona
Max Jets was an elderly eccentric who
occasionally visited the Smith family
showering them with cash and extravagant
gifts he made his fortune by
blackmailing Bill Gates and has just
finished a six-year prison sentence for
an unspecified crime in the season 8
episode Max jets in it the Smiths warmly
welcomed Max to their home each vying
for his financial attention before long
a gold digging waitress is trying to
secure Max's wealth for herself Max uses
his comically large quantities of money
to act like a jerk to ensure their
relationship with Max stayed intact and
that that River of gifts Max
continuously gave them didn't dry up the
Smiths allowed Max to act as crudely as
he wanted no matter how poorly Max
treated people you have to hand it to
him he had style from hiring a celebrity
musician to perform at his wedding to
Flying a panda bear from China to
officiate the ceremony Max Jets is
without a doubt one of the mo most
flamboyant personas that Roger has ever
created it's just a shame that his son
Jerry schemed with his fiancee to kill
him for his fortune with Roger
essentially stealing from himself
taking his inspiration from the Jennifer
Lopez song Jenny From the Block Jenny
From the Block is the teenage girl
Persona Roger adopts when he dates snot
in the season 6 episode bearing her name
after seeing snot get rejected by Haley
Steve and Roger formulate a plan to
cheer him up creating Jenny as a way to
boost snot's confidence Jenny and snot
are soon official when Steve begins to
think the romance has gone too far he
reveals one of the several lies Roger
has been telling snot to make their
relationship appear authentic however
Steve is shocked to find both snot and
Roger emotionally torn apart by the
ending of the relationship prompting him
to try and get the two back together as
Jenny Roger manages to patch things up
with snot only to fake her death by
having Jenny get hit by a bus a native
of New Jersey Jenny is among Roger's
most likable characters her relationship
with snot may have been based on a lie
but she began to feel legitimate
affection for the struggling teen as
they dated like with his other
non-violent personas it can be hard to
know whether Roger is being totally
genuine but in the end Jenny wanted what
was best for snot
Ruby zeldestine is a medium who Roger
invents when the Smiths become haunted
by a supernatural presence in the season
9 episode poltergasm having been
unnerved at the odd happenings occurring
within the Smith household Roger calls
in the one person he believes can help
I'm a maybe him to the other side and I
make a hell of a shoe fly pie
are we really gonna do this an obvious
parody of the Poltergeist character tan
China played by a Zelda Rubinstein Ruby
explains that Francine's years of
frustration in the bedroom have somehow
manifested into a physical presence this
presence will dwell in the house until
Francine's desires are fulfilled the
great thing about Ruby is how utterly
unhelpful she is over the course of the
episode she's able to figure out what
the cause of the disturbance is but
she's otherwise useless appearing more
concerned about her paycheck than
actually helping the Smiths arguably her
Shining Moment comes when she quickly
draws a symbol in the air after telling
the Smiths about the poltergasm
phenomenon informing them she has the
term trademarked and they will have to
reimburse Ruby should they produce any
scripts they write about their
experiences in the house
Roger has always been prone to Dramatics
and his sensitivity and tendency to get
easily offended have been the basis for
numerous American Dad episodes over the
years a notable example of this comes in
the form of the Phantom who appears in
the season 4 episode Phantom of the
Telethon when the US government pulls
critical funding from the CIA Stan looks
for a way to raise money for the agency
after mocking Roger's idea to start a
Telethon Stan takes the idea to his
superiors and then proceeds to take
credit for it himself as Revenge Roger
dons the ghost white half mask of the
famous musical character sabotaging
stands Telethon considering how weird
and wonderful Rogers roster of
characters is the Phantom had no
business standing out so much However
the fact that Roger takes this role so
seriously really sells it elevating this
vigilante to a distinguished spot on
this list his constant attempts to
derail the Telethon range from harmless
pranks like tying stance bow tie and
messing up the teleprompter to dropping
an entire boat on Jeff his dedication to
the role even sees him trying to reenact
several scenes from the original musical
including abducting Steve and dressing
him as Christine dying
yellow journalism is one of the most
dishonest disingenuous tactics a news
organization can employ to boost ratings
knowing that it shouldn't be surprising
that Roger indulges in it during the
season 9 episode news glance with
Genevieve events
look how sad everyone is
get this trying to settle down in a
legitimate profession Haley begins
interning for a news reporter only to
find out that the reporter is actually
one of Roger's personas a no-nonsense
news anchor named Genevieve events at
first Haley tries to focus on stories of
importance to her highlighting
environmental issues she feels are
underrepresented in most news outlets
Genevieve however quickly squashes her
aspirations underscoring the value of
ratings above all else when Haley
convinces Steve to run away for what she
hopes will be a small news story to
pique her audience's interest Genevieve
takes her story and runs with it
eventually framing Stan Francine and
Haley for kidnapping Steve and holding
him hostage in the woods favoring
tabloid journalism and Sensational news
over factual reporting Genevieve will
lie and falsely mislead her entire
audience so long as it means her program
earns high ratings she's without a doubt
one of the most irredeemably twist did
of Roger's disguises
perhaps Roger's most famous and
successful Persona checks lemono helped
the American ice hockey team win the
gold at the 1980 Winter Olympics Stan
discovers this in season 5's the return
of the bling and being a huge fan of the
famous team is totally awestruck that is
until Roger reveals that he was using
steroids at the time Roger's appearance
as Gollum May steal the second half of
the return of the bling but his handful
of scenes his checks are a definite
highlight of the episode as well
captured on a series of still
photographs and old news tapes Roger
shows Stan The Battered and bruised
checks competing against some of the
world's best hockey players more Beast
than man Chex is arguably Roger's most
unstable character prone to
steroid-induced bouts of anger when
given even the slightest provocation at
one point checks attacks his whole team
and a news crew after a teammate
good-naturedly slaps him with a towel a
hilarious Rarity of Dog the Bounty
Hunter horse Renoir is the Persona Roger
adopts after discovering that there's a
bounty for Jeff's arrest in season two's
joint custody Roger partakes in a Roger
Fashion Show to find the right Persona
to pursue Jeff before settling on the
mullet rocking goateeed horse a veteran
bounty hunter from the Bayou horse
demonstrates a complete lack of
knowledge and almost immediately derails
his new career for example when he tries
to track Stan by calling the credit card
company he completely bungles the whole
thing by being unable to answer basic
questions about Stan of course it's
normal for Roger to think of elaborate
backstories for his characters and then
fail to live up to the Persona he
actually creates horses everything a
bounty hunter should be he's an
unprofessional cowardly overly sensitive
biker who hates confrontation and he
nearly kills himself and Stan
accidentally several times throughout
the episode
one of the funniest aspects about
Roger's numerous personalities is how
many of them have a life outside the
Smith residence take for example Frank
trueblue an aspiring police officer who
flunked out of the academy and who is
now in a relationship with a
mild-mannered woman named Stacy in the
season 12 episode a nice night for a
drive as Frank and the family drive down
the highway Steve and his friends egg is
Carr as retaliation for the prank The
Irate Frank chases Steve all over
Langley Falls threatening to run him
over while basically holding Stacy and
her family hostage luckily before Frank
can kill Steve Stacy calms him by
mentioning details about the
relationship including a Sentimental
vacation they spent in Montauk according
to Roger Frank's name haircut and
driving a bright blue Dodge Charger are
all the qualifications he needs to be a
police officer he's the definition of a
loose cannon a man who will go into a
dramatic rage when someone drops a fork
at dinner ruining the whole evening but
creating some hilarious moments for
viewers
Roger isn't a follower of the rules by
any stretch of the imagination
frequently mocking most laws and the
individuals that enforce them often to
the Chagrin of The straight-laced Stang
his violations of the law are usually
flagrant but sometimes he's more subtle
for evidence of this look no further
than his shrewd businessman character
Martin sugar who Roger portrays in the
season 6 episode The People vs Martin
sugar Sugar's appearance in the episode
comes when he's summoned to court to
answer for crimes related to his
unethical business practices in
particular the crimes involve
allegations that Sugar ran in
underground Sweatshop using undocumented
immigrants to produce counterfeit luxury
handbags though obviously guilty of his
crimes sugar successfully charms
everyone in court by appearing as a
kind-hearted generous employer of course
the reality couldn't be farther from the
truth burn sugar is a noteworthy Roger
Persona owing to his clashing
personalities on the surface he's a
likable enough guy prone to making lame
jokes as turns out though Sugar's actual
personality is far more Sinister but as
shady as he is we can't help falling for
his nice guy act as easily as the jury
does
as previously mentioned Roger is known
for pursuing multiple lives outside of
his existence with the Smiths many of
his personas have their own individual
careers and complex personal lives to
deal with one of the first examples of
this we see on American Dad is the
character Sydney Huffman the kindly
Bible manufacturer from the episode The
One That Got Away It's Not Unusual for
Roger to inhabit multiple characters at
once but what's interesting about Sydney
is the fact that not even Roger realizes
he and Sydney are the same person
learning that his bank account has been
maxed out Roger tries to find the person
responsible soon coming to the
realization that the thief is actually a
Persona he created that has since gained
a mind of its own the complete opposite
of Roger in every way Sydney is a
well-spoken warm-hearted person who
avoids alcohol drugs and even swearing
the product of Roger's split personality
he's definitely the most down-to-earth
and caring disguise the alien has ever
had unfortunately such kindness could
have never co-existed with someone as
chaotically sociopathic as Roger who
lies to Sydney he assures him that they
can live peacefully side by side only to
literally stab Sydney in the back
oh cheese and crackers
sorry Sid you're a good egg and that
cramps my style the closest disguise
Roger has to a super villain tearjerker
appears prominently in two themed
American Dad episodes season three's
tearjerker and its sequel season 8 for
black eyes only breaking from the
regular continuity of the show the two
episodes Lampoon the James Bond series
of spy films presenting Stan as a secret
agent who regularly combats his Nemesis
the wealthy International terrorist
tearjerker in terms of personality and
appearance tearjerker is more along the
lines of Dr Evil than he is 007's arch
enemy ernstavro blofeld in the first
episode he appears in tearjerker's evil
plan is to make the saddest movie ever
made in the hope that audiences will cry
themselves to death as revenge for
tearjerker not being taken seriously
when he tried to make it as an actor
despite seemingly dying at the end of
the episode tearjerker reappears in for
black eyes only as a reluctant Ally to
stand that is until he betrays him and
sides with the episode's main villain
tearjerker has all the classic makings
of a bond villain there's the
over-the-top name the Striking visual
appearance the overly complex plan for
world domination and the extravagant
secret hideout yeah that's ridiculous
the contractor who built this place
screwed me good gums he's stuck on the
death slide
ultimately it's not even Stan who beats
him in either episode with tearjerker
meeting his end through his own
incompetence or disloyalty
among Roger's most fully realized
characters is Intrepid wedding planner
Genie gold in season 5's shallow vows
Francine and Stan look for a way to
celebrate their forthcoming 20th
anniversary with Roger helpfully
suggesting they renew their vows in an
official ceremony under the care of
Genie gold completely dedicated to her
job Jeannie oversees every aspect of
Stan and Francine's vowel renewal
recreating their original ceremony as
closely as possible Genie also takes it
upon herself to improve some of the
wedding's weaker aspects threatening
Haley and Steve with her Psychopathic
sidekick the leak in the process the
funniest thing about Genie is how
seriously she takes her job she spends
fortunes on her wedding ceremonies and
she carries everything she needs to
guarantee a perfect wedding in her purse
she also somehow has two teenage Sons
enrolled at Columbia's University's film
program to record all her weddings in
order to make DVD copies for guests
showing just how extensive Roger's
disguises can become when he's a away
from The Smiths
officially named Ralph zacklin the leg
man is one half of Roger and Steve's
private investigating Duo wheels and the
leg man the team serves as a comedic
portrayal of 70s and 80s TV private
detectives born out of Roger and Steve's
Avid love for the genre they're
basically playing a children's game when
they adopt their alter egos with wheels
and the leg man seldom leaving the house
on a Case charging 20 a day plus
expenses and using a teddy bear as their
receptionist the leg man is one of the
few identities Roger has who he created
with the help of another person he and
Steve devise an entire continuity for
their fictional series and their
starring detectives establishing leg man
as the bad cop of The Duo plagued by a
troubled past according to Roger legman
was a NASCAR driver who swerved out of
the way to avoid hitting a baby the baby
being somehow also the leg man the leg
man has popped up in several episodes
usually when Roger and Steve are
presented with a mystery that needs to
be solved the these Mysteries range from
small things like trying to find Haley's
missing iPod Shuffle to trying to locate
kidnappers who have taken Francine
hostage no matter what the case is
though Roger is almost always shown to
be the guilty party even if he isn't
entirely aware of it
one of Roger's best celebrity
impersonations came early in the series
run pretending to be Kevin Bacon in
season two's four little words feeling
insecure after overhearing a mother and
daughter commenting on the fact that he
has no nose Roger begins wearing a fake
latex nose to pass as normal in front of
people before long people start
confusing him with the famous Footloose
actor and Roger uses this assumption to
get free stuff out of people throughout
the episode we see Roger pressure people
into giving him expensive Goods simply
because he's a celebrity when they don't
he launches into a tirade calling them
offensive names of course as Roger's
Behavior worsens the more damage he does
to the real Kevin Bacon's reputation
yeah you may be beautiful on the outside
like Kevin Bacon but you're ugly on the
inside like Tommy Lee Jones on the
outside
and the inside seemingly seeing the
error of his ways Roger gets rid of his
false nose and reconciles with Haley and
Steve although it's soon revealed he
merely ditched the disguise after
causing a car accident for which the
real Kevin Bacon is blamed
the closest thing Roger has to a wise
character is Dr penguin an apparent
psychiatrist by trade Roger acts as the
voice of reason for the Smiths when they
come to him with a problem providing
advice and possible solutions to their
issues however as Klaus points out Dr
penguin's Solutions are usually the easy
way out and are in fact harmful ways to
deal with problems and you need to keep
lying what eventually it'll become
second nature and you'll stop feeling
guilty Dr penguin is another of Roger's
disguises that continually pops up
though he usually appears as the
therapist to the Smiths he's also been
shown to run group therapy sessions in
the outside world the income he receives
from his official jobs supports Dr
penguin's drug habits according to Roger
for as frequently unhelpful as Dr
penguin's advice is there are a few
moments where we see him actually reach
people's inner emotions sometimes with a
simple look more often than not though
Dr penguin simply pretends to be a
therapist sometimes even manipulating
his client science disadvantage such as
trying to trick Stan into killing an
innocent man who got the last pretzel at
wetzel's pretzels
Roger is certainly not the nicest or
most sympathetic American Dad character
but even by his standards Ricky Spanish
is one ice cold jerk he's a lying
thieving sociopath there's hardly a
person in this town who he hasn't stolen
from cheated or Worse the mere mention
of his name is enough to drive all of
Langley falls into a Witch Hunt a
character so evil that Roger nearly
destroyed the costume out of fear Ricky
Spanish has wronged every single person
in Langley Falls in some shape or form
the inherent evil runs so deep that he's
shown to corrupt anyone who wears his
costume possessing Stan when he tries
portraying Ricky in season 13's Persona
assistant there aren't many television
characters as vile as Ricky a criminal
who can't help but be bad even when
Roger tries to redeem Ricky he
instinctively ends up betraying Steve
who is trying to help him write some of
his past wrongs despite how impossibly
terrible Ricky is he's the kind of
villain you can't help but love becoming
the highlight of any episode he appears
in he's a truly awful guy but he's also
Roger's best Persona to date
foreign